well let's do this let's talk about the
gas lighting because we we did briefly
mention this but i want to i want to
dive deeper into this this story
because a lot of these antifa people are
motivated by fake news
so earlier on we were talking about this
we have this poll
this is from zach goldberg he says a
recent nationally representative survey
commissioned by skeptic mag
asked respondents to estimate the number
of unarmed blacks killed by police in
2019.
overall 44 percent of liberals guessed 1
000 or more
as compared to 20 of conservatives this
calculation
is based on the crosstabs shared with me
by the researcher
this is this this is crazy man i watched
a prageru video
and it was will whit i think it was
wilbet and he's at the venice skate park
in california and there's three black
dudes and he asks them
how many black people do you think were
killed by cops in 2019
and one guy goes thousands man thousands
and he was like you think thousands the
other guy's like yeah probably thousands
maybe more
and then he was like 19. depend
depending on which statistic you use
so this skeptic mag used the higher
number of 27 because they take into
account
more more circumstances i think the the
official number of
unarmed black men shot and killed is
like 13
but then when you take into
consideration like maybe like chokeholds
and stuff like that goes up to about 27
27 each and every one of those unarmed
individuals who died
is a nightmarish tragedy i
i i don't even believe the death penalty
man i i really don't i think if you've
subdued someone
then we have to deal with like how i
don't i don't have all the answers i
just tell you this
i think if we got someone locked in a
box and you're like now we're going to
kill you i think that's insane
they're no longer a threat you've got
them locked in you're locked in in this
prison
so i'm opposed to that so if a cop comes
out and gets into a situation
and someone dies that's that's a
nightmare scenario because we have a
constitution we have a bill of rights
we're innocent until proven guilty
but i also recognize that these cops
aren't going out hunting people down
but that's the narrative you're getting
from the media these young people then
believe it the craziest thing about the
story
this other chart we brought up check
this out when they asked conservatives
what percentage of people killed by
police were black that conservatives had
37.8 percent
that's that the number is actually 23
23.4
23.4 percent of the people who were
killed by cops in 2019 were black
even conservatives overestimate the
total number by about 50
so whatever is going on with the media
that even conservatives
are skeptical of they're still buying
into these narratives well it's
visual it's because of visual persuasion
the a very
non-political way that that survey was
done is if you pulled the american
public and you said what
of population you think is why you know
hispanic black most people would say
they think one in four people in america
are black and if you ask them what
percentage of population is gay
you get something from like five to 25
percent and
the answer is that well if you if you're
doing a billboard you have four people
you can't put four white people because
that would be racist so you have to put
you know okay we need a woman here we
need a black here we need a gay person
here
you know we have all the representation
and then people see that over and over
and over and over again
so that that misunderstanding is the
same thing with combat nests if you say
hey what percentage of
combat fatalities do you think are like
female versus male and they'll be like
well like 25
or female or some high number you're
like no it's like less than one percent
yeah yeah it's like way way down the
list and that's because
medium is the message visual persuasion
even if you're
even if it's a good point because i
believe in representation i believe i
agree with the left in terms of
representation matters
you should have positive role models of
every kind of
race religion represented because that
does matter because kids watch that
because
media is so important so people grew up
in the 80s and they watch action movies
they go to the gym
it's unconscious nobody's saying hey go
look like sylvester stallone but like
it's it's there on a conscious level so
i actually believe in representation
but even when it's meant to be done in
good faith people
then draw the wrong conclusions and then
when it's done in bad faith which is
what the media is doing hands up don't
shoot
all the various hoaxes you're
terrorizing i mean the wild thing about
it is
this probably a weird thing that people
won't expect me to think but i would say
that
black men are the biggest victims of the
media hoaxes
because when i leave the house i you
know i know as a lawyer
if i get pulled over things you get
dodgy you should be careful all the time
i tell people that whatever you are
but i don't think that i'm gonna get
hunted down by anyone
you know i don't think that i'm gonna
get hunted down by a gang of black
teenagers or
the police or anyone else there's a
large percent of the population
there's actually somebody who worked for
the nra uh a black guy and he would say
that
or african-american or poc or whatever
you're allowed to say now is
he used to actually believe that white
people with guns were going to hunt him
down
what a terrible way to live scary many
and that's because you've been gaslight
well so
the crazy thing is when i went to sweden
there were a lot of conservative
personalities
talking about the migrant crime waves
and things like that they were showing
these videos of burning cars and the
most egregious stuff
and what i discovered was they were
right there was a crime wave in sweden
one uh uh the previous year they had a
total of one murder
the next year it went up to like 13. for
the people of the town of
the city of malma that was nightmarish
it was like why are these people being
killed
but for someone from chicago i was like
is that it
so what happens is people in the u.s
hear a story
murders are up over a thousand percent
and if you live in chicago
your perspective is based on the chicago
murder rate of being crazy
then you'd imagine your world a thousand
a thousand percent increase in murder
you'd be imagining crazy
insanity back i'm not going to sweden
but you actually go there and you're
like oh i get it
crime is up it's it's up quite a bit
this has the residence
scared but relative to where i'm from
crime is extremely and ridiculously low
so what happens is i think there are
people
who are correctly pointing out the crime
waves but basing the reality situation
off of their personal experience in say
london where there is like more crime
they then put out videos or or new york
or chicago or baltimore
and then they make it seem because in
their world view
it is crazy to see this massive increase
in murders for people who lived in
sweden
they were shocked by these numbers but
they're not used to it
so their their fear was legitimate when
these people in sweden would say we're
terrified to go outside
they mean it but it's not the same thing
you know if you're not from there you
wouldn't know
well and a lot of that's in good faith
too which is
why like i'll give an example like i
used to be because i grew up in a small
town
terrified of big cities right i wouldn't
want to go to new york and get shot
you're going to go chicago to get mugged
and then i started traveling more
and then i would meet people from the
city who were afraid of the country we'd
be driving down they're like oh my god
country roads is this gonna be the texas
chainsaw massacre
is it gonna be deliverance all over
again so there there is other rising
where
okay i grew up in the rural area and
actually it's incredibly dangerous in
terms of driving car accidents a deer
runs out and i'm afraid of going to
chicago to go shopping a miracle mile
i'm actually safer in miracle mile than
i am driving my car at night
because some deer is not going to you
know run out of the road so that's not
even malicious
but then with the media because there's
all these cognitive biases
the availability bias so the last thing
you hear is what you think happens all
the time so for example
there was that famous case where the the
airline pilot
like i think captain sullivan or sully
landed in water
and then after he landed in water oh my
god an emergency
we have to now have water life life
jackets and every kind of plane you're
like
that happened one time in 10 years yeah
you know but but if you're the guy who
says that happened one time in 10 years
it is what it is
now you're going to be massacred by the
media oh you don't care if kids drown
in a pool so that that's always going to
happen too and it happens to us
even when you're trying to to act in
good faith and to tell the
truth i worked at o'hare airport and
they hired
a safety coordinator guy so they have
the the bag room where the conveyor belt
brings all of your luggage when you drop
it off
and so i guess one day this is what i
was told i don't know if it's true but
this is what i was told
somebody had something on their boot and
slipped
and so the next day i come in and
they've glued
this grit down to the floor all across
the floor
and it made it a lot harder to drive
across because it was super grippy
material
and it was really funny to like walk
over it was like they took like
sandpaper glued to the floor and uh i
was like so like one guy
trips and that's their response well
they don't want to be sued yep so if one
guy got hurt
the next time someone gets hurt they're
gonna spend you know thousands and
thousands of dollars they're like spend
a couple hundred bucks and glue the
sandpaper to the floor
so it was an overreaction but it's also
i guess just we have a system built in
place where nobody wants to assume any
risks
nobody wants to recognize that sometimes
accidents happen but also some people
exploit that accident for personal gains
well you don't want to be an adult
that's where you know one of the things
i don't like how trouble
handled coronavirus i'm not here to
defend that but like one thing he said
was hey man you know like
people die it is what it is and the
answer is
yes i i mean a a lot of people are going
to die this year going to like
die different things there are
trade-offs what do you
you can't just be like every death is a
tragedy i mean it is to me you know if i
die it's a tragedy to my family or
friends or whatever but if you're in a
leadership position the answer is like
yeah i mean people die dude like what
are you gonna do you stop the world
you shut everything down because people
are gonna die but then if you say that
now you're a monster
oh this person doesn't care about anyone
he's killing grandma that's that's
that's the scary reality of what's going
on is that everything has to be perfect
all the time like i see these tweets
from aoc and she you know
there was like some lefty who said uh
what did they say no one should ever
have to live in poverty
and it was like someone responded a
person that is a viral tweet
a person who was working full time
should not be living in poverty and they
responded with a snapback
no one should be living in poverty
poverty is relative
poverty 100 years ago was like people
sleeping in a mud pit
and rockefeller had had garbage dental
care now
poor people in this country are
overweight and have air conditioning and
refrigerators and tvs
that's look i'm not saying life is great
for them i would like to see them live
better i would like to see the standard
go up but the standard is going up
if no one can ever live in poverty well
i don't know what to tell you man
because it's relative
well and luke's been around you know
like i thought i grew up poor and like i
you know i got the creds to say i grew
up poor and then i went cambodia and i
was like all right dude
you had a yard bro you had a yard you
didn't really grow a poor
yeah i mean traveling to places like
philippines and africa and somalia it
really gives you a lot of different
perspectives but you
you were also born in the soviet union
yeah or poland yeah but but but again
what's happening here it's everything's
becoming so political everything's
becoming this kind of emotional
manipulative mind control
and it's being played over and over
again just to make sure that we are
convinced that something is happening
when we look at the way that the media
has been acting they've been acting
very very intelligently when it comes to
their propaganda
there's a reason they repeated the
george floyd murder tape
over and over and over again and when we
talk about you know that particular
event whether you have questions about
it or not
it brought up a lot of emotions for a
lot of people
that a lot of people capitalized on for
their own personal political benefit
whether it was true or not it didn't
matter people saw it and got to see it
all the time when it comes to other
people let's just say you know ashley
babbitt getting killed
you don't see that footage on cnn for a
particular reason this is why the
vietnam
war it was on cnn they paid the guy the
the lefty activist
but as far as like the you if you
compare the footage to george floyd i
think there's a big
disparity as far as how much it's played
how it's played and the coverage behind
it
the music behind it the the zooming in
on it the face of a man dying in front
of you
is dramatic uh but we have to understand
these are selectively chosen
to have a bigger agenda out there when
you brought up you know covid
if we treated obesity like covet cancer
like covet the opioid epidemic like
covid especially with the number of
debts with a number of people's affected
by that
my goodness we would never get out of
the door ever but
covet is something else that's being
treated in this own special unique way
but obesity depression child suicide
rates all those issues that are
effective
of of the lockdowns we're not we can't
even talk about it 300 000 people die
per year from obesity
no we we've got to lock everything down
yep we got we got to shut it all down
it's 300 000 people diabetes i mean if
you if you factor diabetes and heart
disease and that
probably more you know if you look at it
like lifestyle what the top 10 most
prescribed pharmaceuticals
eight out of ten are lifestyle what are
the most what are the most incredulous
things that i saw
was a pepsi advertisement uh saying that
your next covet test is going to be at
walmart
i mean how ridiculous could yeah pepsi
was there was a pepsi advertisement that
said get your coveted test now at
walmart
and i'm like are you freaking kidding me
especially when you look at the
scientific studies there's a meme i
tweeted of this like morbidly of base
guy with all the kfc and all this fast
food
and the byline says americans be like
you have no right to go outside and
endanger my health there's no real
conversations about health there's no
real conversations about stress
sleep meditation fasting supplements
making sure you get enough exercise
there's no conversations about that
but there is conversations about
restricting your freedoms taking away
your liberties taking away your money
taking away your livelihood taking away
your existence
for the benefit of the state and it's
ridiculous and it's six and it's
two-faced
and it needs to be called out more than
ever yeah thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast
monday through friday at 8 p.m where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you